massive fire the three-story condominium
breaks out this morning just off the 95
and rancho look at that smoke it
happened at the
bonanza park studios more than a hundred
people
had to get out madison kimbrough spoke
to residents along with the red cross on
where they go from here
the red cross is assisting residents
here at the doula community center many
are just here to cool down get some
drinks and really piece together
what happened at the bonanza park
condominiums earlier this morning
residents say the fire alarm went off
around 8 30 and then they saw black
smoke
las vegas fire and rescue evacuating
everyone
then a short time later the roof caved
in paul ellison and terry key say they
didn't have any time to grab
any of their belongings the condo filled
with smoke really fast
i tried to go back in just to get our i
don't have a wallet i don't have
my cell phone she doesn't have a purse
all of our medications
tons of smoke black smoke fire shooting
up real high
in the air everybody's trying to run out
get out of their apartment
the fire is believed to have started on
the third floor but no word yet on the
cause
at last check 30 people are looking for
a new place to live
and the red cross says they'll be here
all afternoon to assist
according to fire officials they are
letting people back
inside the building as of now the fire
caused half a million dollars in damage
reporting from bonanza and las vegas
boulevard madison kimbrough 8 news now